let's talk about cop 27 the
International Conference on climate
change opens this weekend in Egypt it's
the first time since 2016 that the
Summit is happening on African soil an
opportunity for the continents to
address
urgent issues for example According to
some estimates Africa loses between 7 to
15 billion dollars a year due to climate
change despite only emitting less than
four percent of global emissions by
comparison industrialized countries like
the US Canada China Japan and large part
of Western Europe have contributed about
50 percent of Planet warming greenhouse
gases over the past 100 years as a
result African countries now see more
extreme weather like massive flats and
recurring droughts
so at cup 27 African governments will
push hard for a deal to tackle the
impact of climate change one of those
countries in the Sahel is Niger its
foreign minister hasumi masudu believes
the region needs a huge financial
package
we have estimated that 440 billion
dollars would be needed between 2018 and
2030. to be able to face the climate
challenge in the Sahel region
especially to adapt to and mitigate the
damage
so these climate issues are Global
issues for Humanity
they require Global solidarity we have
drought here because of the actions of
others
we are not responsible
that was foreign minister asumi masudu
now while some parts of Africa suffer
severe droughts other parts are
experiencing heavy and frequent
rainfalls as is currently happening in
Nigeria a small town in a Democratic
Republic of Congo is also dealing with
overflows from Lake Tanganyika one of
the world's largest lakes the fishing
communities have already been suffering
from high water temperatures killing
fish now the rise in water levels and
mud slides are further devastating the
community
the lake is eating away at homes bit by
bit and meter by meter the water has
risen so high
the thousands of people in the town of
kalemi have been displaced
here was a very nice house
on the other side all the people have
fled
we don't know where to get help so that
we can rebuild
look at all this closely
Tanganyika is the world's second deepest
freshwater lake local residents depend
on its fish to make a living But Rising
water temperatures have killed Mass
amounts of fish on top of that the lake
has become a danger to the people it
once fed
floods and storms are common in tropical
countries like the Democratic Republic
of Congo but climate change is now
making them more frequent and more
severe now when it rains the Earth
slides that's washed huge chunks of silt
into the lake and cause water levels to
Surge
the rise according to this official has
been very rapid
Lake Tanganyika has risen to a level of
more or less five to six meters in
height an advanced 200 to 250 meters in
land towards the continent in three
years
foreign
residents each day has become
unpredictable
the hope is that the global Community
will take note of it
and that's why world leaders government
officials and other delegates will
attend this year's climate change
conference in Egypt many young climate
activists will also be there and how
they are now of speaking to one of them
Anita soina a 22 year old environmental
activist and author from Kenya she told
me why it was so important for her to
attend the cop 27.
I first of all believe that the only
qualification that we all need to confab
the environment or participate in
climate action is the fact that we live
in this planet and the fact that uh they
say there's no Planet B uh there is no
livable planet B we only have one at and
I uh that makes it the reason why we as
young people should come and protect the
planets another thing is looking uh it's
not only affecting our future it is
affecting our presence so they the need
for all of us to come together as one
voice to Champion for climate action
very eloquently said now a while ago you
said quote we already feeling the effect
of the climate crisis there's nowhere to
quarantine from the climate crisis
therefore we must act now are you saying
that leaders are not doing enough to
tackle climate change
oh yes uh I'll have previously not
tackle climate crisis is a crisis that
it is it has been
um
times and conferences and meetings of
discussions and commitments being put in
place but not really being taken at the
crisis that it is why I say so it's
because it has taken um loss of life uh
serious hunger that we're having now in
Kenya are mad slides Landslide flooding
even in the Western countries for
leaders to actually start looking at it
like it is an emergency when clearly all
these things happening were predicted
before so if they took this as an
emergency that it is I believe that we
would not be having uh
um the worst effect of climate change
that we're having right now I remember
when I joined the space
I used to hear these uh this uh saying
that scientists are warning that by 2030
we are going to have the wealth impacts
of climate change being irreversible so
this is to say that there has been
scientific knowledge before but there
has been little action towards um
climate another thing is also um I am
looking at covid yeah the reason I say
um so it's because of covered covet
showed us that our leaders can actually
act if they want to
when we had no coveted cases a day like
today and a day like tomorrow we have
one covered case and there was money
being put in place to contain uh coffee
there was a lot of com a lot of action
towards containing covered so I was
trying to imagine you know for coffee at
least three equal self-isolate we could
quarantine in the house but for climate
change I don't know how you can
quarantine from flooding so it is
clearly clear that um if they could act
swiftly on that then it could be easy on
this and for this we cannot self-isolate
yeah totally I mean as you said there's
no Planet B so this is the only planet
that we have tell us you particularly
have a personal connection to climate
change what is it
um yeah I'd say uh growing up as a
person from the Maasai community that I
uh proudly belong to we have been the
most affected uh one of the most
affected communities by climate change I
mean uh we have had droughts before but
this time it's been very severe with
almost uh four years of no short and
long rates
um we I remember growing up elsewhere uh
from my mom's family which is away from
the Maasai Community we used to farm for
we used to farm Maids twice a year but
today because of changing weather
patterns and rainfall distribution you
realize that we have to farm Maize only
once a year so these are the things that
have also affected food production we
have the water scarcity issue it's
affecting livestock and it's it's
actually even affecting our way of life
yeah it's affecting uh everything
including culture
which now um we as pastoralists have to
start thinking how we are going to live
differently how we are going to do our
way with with uh with livestock so that
we can be able to adapt to the current
climatic change situations and possible
future effects as well
Kenyan climate activist Anita suena
there so what does Africa need to tackle
climate change that's a question I put
to trukumarija a professor of global
climate and environmental governance at
Alex ekwueme Federal University in
Nigeria
so five things basically first there
needs to be a clear plan
second there needs to be a clear policy
uh third there needs to be Finance
a force there needs to be technical
capability and the fifth one there needs
to be strong International collaboration
actually when you look at African
countries you see that many of them have
already
uh ticked the Box in about two or three
of those so uh nearly all African
countries have a big ambition to tackle
climate change as contained in their
nationality determined contribution some
African countries have already gone
ahead to make Net Zero pledges for
example Nigeria has a net zero pledge by
2060. and also has a National Climate
Change act one thing you mentioned
sorry to catch you the one thing you
mentioned in your uh Five Points that
you made was the financial part right
financing is very key in helping to
tackle climate change and we know that
Africa is going to feel the effect more
while the main polluters maybe not so
much but pledges and commitments have
been made by the industrialized
industrialized nations but they have not
been kept why is Africa not getting the
help it needs
well I think that is the question that
is perhaps even best answered by the
rich countries who have made the
promises and failed to keep them this is
also the question that I have had for
the rich countries for a very long time
they often say that there is no money
but what we saw with the covid-19 was
that when they needed the money they
were able to get it so how optimistic
are you that world leaders well at the
end of cop 27 Walk The Talk
I would like to be but unfortunately I'm
not very optimistic the challenge is
that cop 27 is taking a place at the
time are very difficult a new strategic
landscape with a war in Ukraine but also
the midterm election that is coming in
the United States and so we do not know
even that some of the big leaders will
attend however that has not stopped
African leaders from making the point
that cop 27 has to work for Africa so
let's see how it goes
okay Mary J okay professor of global
climate and environmental governance at
Alex ekwueme Federal University in
Nigeria thank you very much for your
time